Palm 2 is a powerful large language
model from Google in this course you'll
learn how to effectively use Palm 2 and
its API to enhance your productivity and
develop AI powered applications Ana Kubo
teaches this course she is one of our
most popular instructors so let's start
learning hi everyone and welcome to this
full course on Google's large language
model Palm 2 my name is Anna Kuba and
I'm a software developer as well as
course creator here on free Camp as well
on my own channel if you are new to the
world of large language models this
course is the perfect video for you we
will be starting completely from scratch
introducing you to this wonderful world
that power some of the most powerful AI
tools today such as Google's B for
example by the end of this course you'll
be able to confidently use the Palm 2
API as well as hopefully gain some
knowledge about the world of AI in
general in fact here's a whole list of
the things that we we will be covering
in the next hour or so so we will first
look at why use Palm 2 followed by what
is AI and large language models in
general we will then get set up look at
tokenization AI hallucinations
authentication the models that come with
p 2 and finally we're going to build our
own AI chatboard so that's at the end I
hope you're excited what are we waiting
for let's do it first off why use pal 2
googus palom 2 is an advanced large l
anguage model or llm designed to be more
effective at a range of task than its
predecessor P before we get to
demystifying some of the words in that
sentence such as llm let's actually
understand why we would want to use
something like Palm to in the first
place if you are a developer here's some
reasons you might think about using Palm
2 first up let's look at its
multifunctionality Palm 2 is capable of
various tasks including code generation
this means you can use it for helping
you code debug your code or explain code
so imagine you have this component here
written in JavaScript and suddenly the
team decides they want to start using
typescript you can literally ask
Google's AI tool Bard built using Palm 2
to convert the code for you into
typescript another thing you can ask it
to do is literally write the code for
you from scratch Palm 2 in comparison to
its predecessor Palm has been
pre-trained on a broader range of data
sources meaning it has better
multilingual capabil ities and can
handle diverse programming languages
from popular ones like python to more
specialized ones like foran however
please do keep in mind that taking this
code with a pinch assault is advised as
some hallucinations or in other words
guess workor could have been done and
just like we did all of that with code
you can also do various tasks with
mathematical reasoning natural language
generation question answering and
translation heck with p 2 he even has
been trained on data to make it better
understanding nuances in human language
such as idioms and riddles pretty sure
it's good at sarcasm too Palm 2 just
like Palm it predecessor also emphasizes
safety in terms of responsible AI
development Google has taken measures to
ensure that Palm to is free from biases
as much as possible and reduces harmful
outputs it's done this by the removal of
personally identifiable information
filtering of duplicate data and
Performing extensive evaluation s to
measure potential harms and biases and
finally Palm 2 also offers API access
for developers developers can leverage
the Palm 2's capabilities via the Palm
API which we'll be using today making it
easier to build applications requiring
Advanced natural language processing
capabilities this can be beneficial for
Content generation chatbots
summarization classification and more
this is the API we'll be using to build
out our project at the end in summary as
a developer you can see pal 2 as a tool
that offers a wide array of capabilities
ranging from natural language processing
to coding assistance I'm excited to use
it via the API soon but first what is AI
artificial intelligence is a simulation
of human intelligence processes by
machines I say simulation as artificial
intelligence is not sentient at at least
not yet anyways meaning it cannot think
for itself as much as it may seem it
does often and this is certainly the
case with tools such as this one for
example when we say AI we are simply
referring to a term called machine
learning machine learning works by using
large amounts of training data that is
then analyzed for correlations and
patterns these patterns are then used to
predict outcomes based on the training
data provided so for example if I was to
feed this training data basically
summarizing what each paragraph is about
so for example here we are feeding in
data saying that a paragraph looks like
this with this type of title should be
categorized as international finance the
second paragraph should be put in the
category of earning reports and so on
and with some code we should be able to
train our AI model to correctly guess
what future paragraphs are about and
that's it of course that is a super
basic example and we would need way more
data than these five paragraphs right
here but you get the idea if you want to
build your own AI model and understand
the con concepts of machine learning
better as a total beginner please do
check out my video on it on my channel
code with ANUK kuo for now however let's
not make our own model but use an
existing model or large language model
Palm 2 starting off with getting our API
key in order to communicate with it
first just like most apis the Palm 2 API
uses API keys for authentication in this
section I'm going to show you how to get
your own API key when it comes to
communicating with the API from the
applications that we will be building
remember make sure not to share or
upload your API key anywhere public if
you do someone might take it and use it
for their own projects and use up all of
your free tokens or rack up a huge
credit card bill if you have a credit
card attached this also includes
exposing in any client side code by this
I mean building an app without a backend
and deploying onto the internet the code
in this case will be visible simply by
inspecting it like so someone will then
be able to go and get it and take it
from here for their own use to use this
key safely request must be rooted
through your own backend server where
your API key can be securely loaded from
an environment variable or Key
Management Service okay so in order to
get your API key make sure to visit this
URL and then simply explore the API and
then get your API key this is super
simple all I'm going to do is click get
my API key and agree to the terms of
service and then simply create API key
in new project so that's all you're
going to do and here it is you can copy
it and make sure to keep it somewhere
safe as mentioned okay and then you can
delete it if you don't want it anymore
and create a new one as well that is
totally up to you just make sure you
have your API key ready for creating our
projects but first let's have a look at
the models available in Palm 2 next in
Palm 2 we have many generative models we
can use I'm going to take you through
four of the more popular ones using the
rest API please note there are many ways
to interact with palm 2 including an SDK
with no. JS as well as all these ways
you can see here if you would like to
play around with them please do so for
the sake of making this tutorial as
accessible to as many developers as
possible I will stick to using the the
rest API with a c command however so
let's do it let's start with the
generate text model first the generate
text model generates a response from the
model given an input message this means
we can use it to ask pomp to a question
to which you will return a response for
example let's have a look at this step
by step okay so we're going to write a
call command we're going to go to a
specific URL so let's get up our quote
and I'm just going to paste it so it's
htps generative language. googleapis.com
we're going to use V1 beta 2 uh we're
going to get the models and the models
we're going to get it's going to be for
text so we're going to use text bison
one and then we're going to use the
generate text model and we're going to
put in our API key so just make sure to
put in your API key we did get this in
the last section so if you ski that
please have a a look at how to get your
own API key this is mine and this will
be disabled soon okay and end quote next
just make a space and now we're going to
write our header and our header is going
to say
application Json for the content type
once again this is a string so put it in
these quote marks great make a space and
next we're going to Define this as a
post so I'm just going to put X post cuz
it's a post request and as the data well
I'm going to have an object I'm just
going to paste it like so here is our
object and as the prompt we have another
object and it just going to be some text
and this is essentially the text or the
string we want to send over to the Palm
to API in order to get a response so we
wanted to write a story about a magic
backpack okay and just hit enter and let
it do its thing and and here we go so
here we have it we received an object
back and the output okay so this is an
array and the output is a Story Once
Upon a Time there's a young boy named
Billy who love to go on adventures so
this should be a story about a backpack
we have some other stuff here we have
safety rating as well we have a category
and probability so I'm going to talk to
you a little bit more about what else we
going to send over with our request next
with the generative text model as we saw
we sent over a prompt this is an object
as we saw so this right here this is an
object that has text as an attribute and
the text or string as a value okay so
this is required however we have a bunch
more things that we could to passed
through with this which we did not these
are safety settings stop sequences
temperature and this controls the
randomness of the output with zero being
essentially less creative and values
closer to one being more creative we
also have a candidate count Max output
tokens top p and top X I will not be
using these in the tutorial okay this is
a bit more advanced I'm just showing you
a basic way in order to generate text
however if you are interested in this
please do pause here and make a note of
these and have a read through them in
your own time for now let's continue
next up we have the generate message
model this is us to have more of a
conversation in which we feed in not
just a string so just one question but a
bunch of previous conversations that
we've had with the llm okay so this just
means that it can build on the previous
conversation and build on the previous
stuff that you told it I'm going to show
you how to do this now so first off
we're just going to write curl and then
we're going to paste in the URL so once
again let's make this a string and this
time I'm just going to show you where
this goes this goes to the generative
language. googleapis.com V1 beta2 models
chat this time bison instead of text and
we're going to use the generate message
model and we're just going to put in our
API key so just like we did before okay
great once again we need to put in the
header this is going to be once again
content type application Json so just
like so as a string and then I'm going
to Define this as a post request with
the data and the data once again this is
going to be an object it's going to have
the property of prompt so just like so
however this time it's going to take
multiple messages so I've made an array
in which we can put objects that will
represent one one message so this one
message essentially has the content of
high that's going to be our first
message and if I just go ahead and hit
enter we get the response so this is
what we sent over these are all our
messages there's just one in there for
now it says hi that's what we sent over
and this is the response okay so the
responses are going to be saved under
candidates here's an array of them and
the response essentially is high how can
I help you today simple just like with a
generate text model we can also have
different parameters on this occasion we
can have a temperature so again setting
zero to be less random and one to be
essentially more random or more creative
we can also have a candid account and
this can return multiple responses you
can set the candid account to B1 for
example and actually as a default it is
one or you can choose a value between 1
and8 we also have top p and top K which
we will not be covering in this tutorial
however if you want to have a look at
them please pause here and read through
this documentation now great let's
continue so let's go ahead and add some
more messages in here right so I'm going
to just get that back up again and we're
going to send this over to this year URL
to generate message okay but we're going
to pass through a bunch more messages so
here is our first message right so it's
the first object that has content High
I'm just going to essentially put a
comma right after it and paste it and
this time as the content I'm going to
put the string of remember my name is
Anna and ask me a question so I'm
sending over two messages now hi and
remember my name is Anna and ask me a
question
and let's see what we get
back and great so here are the messages
we sent over that's the full array
that's the first message of hi and this
is the second one of remember my name is
Anna and ask me a question and then the
response is hi Anna it's nice to meet
you how can I help
today great now let's have a look at how
many tokens this cost us next so as we
are making a request it is us ful to
know that this is costing us tokens each
word is tokenized okay and it can be
hard to figure out exactly how many
tokens are being used we can essentially
use a HTTP request to find out exactly
how many tokens are use for a message as
well as text however we're just going to
look at the messages for now so I'm
going to use the count message tokens
model so let's go ahead and do it I'm
just going to get get up my terminal
once more and in fact I'm just going to
bring up the last thing that we did so
here we have curl and this is generate
message as well as our API key and then
as the header we have content ey
application Jason this is a post request
and as the data again we have the prompt
with messages the array of two messages
okay and all I'm going to do is just
switch out the URL so all I'm going to
do is change this right here generate
message
token to count
token just like so and it should
calculate exactly how many tokens these
messages cost me okay so just say enter
and the token count is
27 great okay so we're now really done I
just want to touch on one topic and that
is touch on the topic of creating text
embeddings now this is a super
interesting and advanced topic and I
really recommend you watch my video on
Vector embeddings in order to fully
understand this because I cannot fit
this it's outside of the scope of this
tutorial but essentially the Palm to API
will also allow us to create text
embeddings or in other words Vector
representations of words for us to be
able to search large databases for
similar words okay so I'm quickly going
to show you how to do this we're going
to use the curl command and then we're
going to use the embedding text model
along with our API key so once again
this is the URL we're going to embedding
Gecko and then we're going to use the
embed text model and we're going to put
in our API key so this one is mine
please use your own finish off that
string then we're going to put the
header as content type application Jason
just like we have been doing and once
again this is a post request and as the
data this time I'm simply going to put
an object and it's going to have the
text that we want to create into a text
embedding so this time is just the
string of say something nice and I'm
going to hit enter and taada it's an
array so this array of numbers
essentially repres
presents the text of say something nice
which means that we can now use this
array in order to search for similar
texts in a large language model so this
is something that is super interesting
please go ahead and watch this video
after this if you have time otherwise
let's continue with building out our
Palm to chatbot so we've learned about
the models necessary to do this we've
also leared how to get our API key so
really we're ready to
go okay so let's create a project I'm
going to start off using my code editor
of choice which is webstorm I'm going to
save it in a direct called webstorm
projects and in webstorm I can actually
choose to essentially get the command
npx create react app in order to spin up
an react application so again this is
going to be stored on my computer and
webstorm project I'm going to go ahead
and call this palom to chatbot just like
so okay and I'm going to click create so
there we go that is now doing its thing
it's Sally spinning up all the files we
need in this directory so here's one
file and more will get added for those
of you who aren't using webstorm you can
also choose a directory I'm going to
once again go into webstor projects and
then run the command MPX create react
app followed by whatever you would want
to call the project so for example like
this and hit enter and then this
directory with all the files will be
created in the directory webstorm
projects on your computer but I'm not
going to do it this way as I'm doing it
this way and we're just going to wait
for that to do its
thing and great so here we have the
directory with all the files as you can
see here this is looking wonderful I'm
just going to minimize that so first off
I'm just going to clean this up a little
bit uh we're not going to be using this
app CSS file as it's a small project so
I'm just going to delete this file there
we go delete anyway we're not going to
be writing any tests so that can go as
well no test for this project of course
you can add yours if you want at the end
and I'm going to delete these three too
so the logo and anything to do with
testing or reporting web vitals will go
wonderful so now if we look in the index
JS again I'm just going to delete
everything we don't need so we can get
rid of
that as well as this import I'm also
going to get rid of the semicolons as I
don't want to use them in this project
so that is what the index.js file will
look like at the moment then we've got
the index CSS and I just want to start
fresh so I've deleted all of that and
then we have the appjs file so once
again I'm just going to delete the logo
as we're not importing that anymore
we're not importing the app CSS file I'm
going to change this to a functional
expression as that is my preference so
just like so just going to minimize that
and again we're just going to stop fresh
so I'm going to delete the content of
all of this and just return a single a
div and delete the semicolons okay so
you should have the appjs file that
looks like this the index CSS file which
is empty and the index JS file which
looks like this great and you will see
that's all in The Source directory now
as this is going to need a backend I am
going to create a backend for this
project I'm going to do it on the same
level as the read me and the package
Json so just go ahead and add a new file
this is going to be a Javascript file so
let's go ahead and make that I'm going
to call it index JS or you can call it
server JS just to be more clear it is up
to you great so we'll go to this in a
bit I just want to build out the UI of
the but first this shouldn't be too
complicated like I said it's super basic
so let's do it first off I'm going to
create a wrapping div and I'm going to
give this the class name of chatbot so
we can pick it out in our
CSS next I'm going to actually have
another div this is going to well we can
make it a I'm just going to give it the
class
name of chat header notice I'm not
putting it in a header element this is
because I don't want to it's not a
technical header to the document now in
here what I'm going to do is also create
another nested div and this is just
going to contain some information so
let's give this the class name of
info container so we can style it up and
I'm going to include the H3 element with
chat with so that's a heading as well as
a
bigger title so that's why I'm using H2
and it's just going to say the Palm to B
great so there we go under here so just
under the info container I'm actually
going to put an SVG but we'll come back
to that and now that is it so that is
our whole chat header under the chat
header I'm going to make another div and
this is actually going to be the feed so
the feed of all the messages so let's go
ahead and give this the class name I'm
going to just do feed like so great and
once in here I'm going to map messages
I'm actually going to map onto two divs
because we're going to have one div for
the question bubble so let's give this
the class name of question as this is
going to be a question and this is also
going to have the class name of bubble
because I want both of these to
essentially look like a bubble but be
differentiated by the color so this is
going to be for the question that we ask
our chat Boot and this is going to be
for the response Okay
cool so that is our feed and under our
feed we're going to have just a I think
we should probably just have a text area
Okay so this is essentially where we're
going to ask the chatbot that question
we're going to write it in and this is a
self closing element uh and it's going
to have a value which is going to be
some text we're going to leave that
blank for now and then and an onchange
event because we want to essentially
save the question to the state of this
component so let's just comment that out
for now and continue and finally I'm
just going to have a button and this
button is also going to have an onclick
which is going to generate the response
okay so essentially this is where all
the Magic's going to happen we're going
to write in some into our chatbot we're
going to click on this button it's going
to send it over to our server and
essentially come back with the answer to
our question from the Palm to
API great on the button I'm also just
going to use this text
icon symbol okay it's this little arrow
right here if you can't see it looks
like
that just make that a bit smaller and
that's essentially a whole app at the
moment if you want to find this text
icon just go ahead and visit this URL
right here in order to get get the same
one and just copy it like so wonderful
okay so now I think it's time to spin up
our app so I'm just going to go ahead
and spin this up by clicking this button
right here and that should spin up our
application so great I'm just going to
comma this out for now in order to get
this to work and wonderful there we go
that's what we should see and I'm just
going to go ahead and inspect this page
in order to get up our console here so
we can debug
now for those of you not using webstorm
I'm just going to stop this from running
you can just go ahead and have a look at
the package Json in order to spin this
up we're just going to use this Command
right here start this just means I'm
just going to shut this down and get up
our
terminal that in here so just make sure
that you're in the project you can do
npm Run
start and that will do the same thing it
will essentially run the app and spin it
up on Local Host 3000 you can do that
there or you can do that on here too
right so you can do CD and then whatever
you saw the project CD pal to chatbot
npm Run start and that will spin up the
app so those three ways are all viable
it's up to you whichever way you want to
do it great so there we go we've spun up
our app let's just get to styling up a
little bit first I'm just going to
minimize that for now so let's get up
our index CSS files first off I'm just
going to grab the whole body the whole
body of the app and I'm going to start
fresh by overriding the margin and
padding to start off with zero and then
I'm just going to change the background
color of this app so background color
and I pricked a color it's a kind of
very light grayish 2 27
227 so that's what it should
be and then I'm just going to make sure
that the chatbot is aligned to a certain
part of the browser so perhaps let's go
ahead and actually start that chatbot
first so let's grab the chatbot I'm
literally looking for the element with
the class name dot means class name of
chatbot and I'm just going to give it a
height of 500 pixels a width of 400
pixels let's give it a background color
as well background color and I'm just
going to go with white so that is the
RGB for
white great while we are here I'm just
going to also uh give it a border radius
and what I'm going to do is make sure
that the top left hand corner is rounded
by 20 pixels top right hand corner is
also but the two bottom ones are zero
now I am going to give it a margin
as
well okay just to space it out a little
bit you will see why so I'm going to go
20 pixels at the top 20 pixels on the
right zero at the bottom and 20 pixels
on the left and finally I'm also just
going to give it a box Shadow okay to
kind of make it pop up from the
background so again I'm using rgba cuz
this time I want to add a
transparent uh I guess argument into
here so I'm going to give it 0.16 for
transparency and the color black and now
I'm going to do zero pixels xaxis 10
pixels ya AIS 36 pixels blur and zero
spread so there we go and then we're
going to do two box Shadows actually so
rgba again this time it's going to be
black but
0.06 is what I'm going to do for opacity
and then essentially just have one pixel
uh spread great so now if we look in
here it looks kind of like this but we
want to position this right I want to
position it so it kind of moves with the
browser and it's always here and for
that I'm going to use display and then
I'm going to initialize Flex box so
flex and I'm going to justify
content
end okay so if we save that it's already
here and I want to go to the bottom as
as well you will see it's not exactly
all the way here because we gave it a
margin right we gave it a margin on all
the three sides apart from the bottom so
now let's move it to the bottom so and
for this I actually need to assign a
height to the body otherwise this will
not work so I'm going 100% of the
viewport height and I'm going to use
align items end as well so now that will
be here and no matter how much I move
the brows and how big I make it it will
always be there and amazing this is
coming out well the other thing I want
to do is to the whole body just add a
font family so I'm going to actually use
Ariel and then sand serif as a backup
while we're here though I'm also going
to add the H2 and H3 element in here for
styling and I'm just going to apply a
margin of five pixels to both okay just
to space those out but also overwrite
any pre-existing margin
great let's move on the next thing I
want to actually grab is the info
container so essentially stuff that
holds this so let's go ahead and do that
I'm going to grab the info container
just like so give it a height of 60
pixels and a
background of um I'm actually going to
use a linear gradient for
this so let's get the linear gradient
method and I'm just going to pass
through RGB so color into here I'm going
to use 22 1
9741 and then RGB 6
12084 okay so at the moment it will look
like this uh and then we're actually
going to add an SVG here to the bottom
but first off we need to essentially
hide any overflow right because at the
moment that box is overflowing what we
set before in terms of the actual chat
bot so I'm actually going to also on the
chatbot do
overflow hidden and that just means that
any overflow is hidden
wonderful uh let's also added padding to
this so all the letters aren't so
squashed up to the sides of the info
container and I'm going to change the
color of the text to be an off white so
not exactly white and that is the color
I'm going to choose so already is
looking much better cool before we move
on to the SVG or anything like that I'm
just going to grab the text area as well
so we've commented out the text area at
the
moment here it is so maybe let's in fact
maybe let's put these back in but just
get rid of these as that is why we are
getting errors so here's our text area
I'm just going to style it up so let's
grab it this is super basic styling
right this is a basic chat bot that you
can take and you know make your own
style it up and all that so position
absolute I'm going to give it and it's
going to be positioned to the chatbot
which means this I'm going to need to
give a position of relative to because
we don't really want this to move but we
do want this to move we want to be
absolute based on where it is in the
chatbot and this just means I can use
bottom zero to place at the bottom zero
of the chatbot element or its parent
element and left zero so if we look in
here it's going to be here bottom zero
left zero right so that's where it would
be and let's style it up a little bit
further now I'm going to get rid of that
border so I'm going to do border none
and make sure the the width like I said
is 100% width of the par
which is the chatbot and the Box sizing
I'm also going to give it border a box
so there's no funky Behavior happening
it's like inside the Box rather than
over spilling and now I'm just going to
give it some padic as well so 25 pixels
on the top 70 pixels on the right
because we're going to put a button
there and 25 pixels on all the other
sides so that's the pattering inside the
text area one last thing I'm going to do
is just add a border just to the top
though I'm going to make it one pixel
solid
and a kind of
off whitish color too so there we go
that's looking good now I don't want the
text area to be in Focus so to get rid
of that this is easy you just grab the
text area once more and when it's in
Focus I just want the outline to be none
so that will get rid of that if you are
curious
great now let's actually grab the Button
as we're going to have to make it
essentially go here so let's do
it let's give it a height I'm going to
give it a height of 40 pixels as well as
a width of 40 pixels as I want it to be
a circle which means that border radius
uh I'm going to give it
50% uh the background color again let's
pick this out I'm going to make it
62084 yes I did pick this out already
it's a green and then the inside so the
text inside which is the arrow is going
to be
207 207 207 so kind of in line with the
off-white we saw before again I need to
position it so I'm going to go a
position of
absolute um and this time from the
bottom of the chat B I'm going to place
it 21 pixels and to the right I'm going
to make it 21 pixels so that it should
appear essentially here
cool now let's also start the bubbles so
we're going to grab anything there
should be two in there with a class of
bubble and each bubble of text that
appears is going to be in a bubble that
is width 250 pixels let's Pat it out 20
pixels I'm going to get a margin from
the top and bottom 10 pixels to space it
out from any other Bubbles and 25 pixels
from the left and right let's also round
it off a little bit uh by 10 pixels so
it's not so harsh it's not a rectangle
and also give it a box shadow Shadow so
this sticks out from the background I'm
going to use rgba make it black and then
for opacity I'm going to put
0.24 and then zero on the x axis three
pixels on the Y AIS and 8 pixels blur in
fact we don't really need that zero here
either cuz the spread if you don't put
anything is automatically
zero great and then the color of the
text in here it's not going to be black
it's going to be an off black I don't
want to be too harsh so that is the
color that I'm going to choose so at the
moment our two bubbles look like this
but we want to give both of them a
different color based on if it's a
question or a response so let's pick out
the
question and the background color for
this I'm actually going to make it
24 24
244 uh and then the response I'm going
to maybe keep it white but what I will
do is override the margin left and just
make it 85 pixels okay so that it's
going to look like that question
response question response I mean we're
pretty much done we just have the SV
Gene last so I left this last so that
you can just stick it in essentially
what I did is went to
SVG
generator so this one right here by high
and then I just made a wave so that's
all I did essentially I'm going to start
designing for free I've got the wave so
that's essentially what it looks like
and then I simply just kind of played
around with it really so just play
around with it yourself you can make it
more or less of a
wave it is up to you and then I just
downloaded it so again do the same
please obviously change the colors to be
more in line with the colors that we
have here so in other words you want
the green here and then for it to go to
White right so please do the same I've
already done this and exported the SVG
so that's what mine looks like you will
see the fill here as well if you are
struggling please feel free to take my
code of course I'm not going to code
this out because that path is just
ridiculous so please do take this from
the code that I've shared in the video
description below or have a go at you
know making this yourself here just like
I told you so just make sure that the
fill here is the same color green so
let's have a look at what green this is
is this
one which is essentially this color code
and the background I mean you can make
it white or you can just hide it
completely okay and then just download
the SVG so wonderful of course you might
need to flip this around so just make
sure to do it by changing the direction
as well okay let's move on I think we're
now ready to actually get some of those
messages coming through so let's do it
so now on the server I'm just going to
define a few things the first one is the
port it's going to be Port 8,000 just
going to make this bigger for you we're
going to have con Express require
Express cuz that's a package we're going
to need for roting and then once we have
this Okay so we've we're going to import
the package express and we're going to
save as the con Express and we're going
to get Express and release all of its
wonderfulness so that's us releasing it
and save it under the const app okay so
we can use it with all of its methods
later on we're also going to need CES so
that we can get rid of any pesky
messages blocking us you know you see
blocked by caes that will help us get
around around that and we're also going
to be working with variables secret
variables and in order to do that we're
going to also require another package is
the EnV package uh and that is
the code in order to be able to use it
in this project okay also as I believe
we are going to be using Json I'm just
going to for safe measure use express
Json here so we can pass it from the
front end to the back end and then I'm
just going to use cause as well so we
can override and then I'm just going to
use cause as well like I said so that
essentially we can bypass when we are
blocked by C great now let's go ahead
and import those so I'm going do npmi
and import Express C andv so just hit
that right there and then in your
package Json file you should see those
popping up so there they are along with
their versions so if you're watching
this in the future and this doesn't work
it could be the version you're using
just revert back to this one right here
so just changed it obviously I'm not
going to and then do npmi again to
reinstall those packages with those
versions cool let's move on so now that
we have those let's actually start up
our back end first I'm just going to
listen out to the port just to make sure
that everything is working so app Listen
port and then we're just going to do
here console
log listening on Port and then the port
number so let's do it I need to get my
package Json file up again and I'm going
to write a script so I'm going to do
start backend and then we're just going
to do noden one we're going to listen
out continuously so that's another
package we need to install npmi noden
one and this will continuously listen
out for changes make sure to save this
first NPA no Dem
one maybe just cut that out first as
it's causing errors and store
that make sure that no Deon is there to
listen out for constant changes and then
just put that back in so no Deon I'm
going to listen out to the file server
JS so there we go okay making sure that
is eight string while we're here I'm
just going to change this script to
start front end so it's more obvious and
let's continue so now that we've done
that let's start up our back end and
this should start up on uh Port 8000 so
I'm going do npm Run
start backend this time I'm not going to
restart the front end as it's already
running so there we go so now if we go
to I'm going to just shut these
down Local Host 8000
there we go and it should say listening
on P 8,000 and it is so everything is
looking good our front end is running
and our back end is running so now we're
going to have to use a few things here
uh we're going to have the language
model API key that we're going to get
from the pal to portal so con
language
model API key
and yes I am going to store this in a
EnV file and the other thing we're going
to need is the URL that we're going to
essentially quot so first off to access
anything in a EnV file let's go ahead
and make it that EnV file. file. EnV we
of course as I mentioned need this
required. EnV in order to use process.
EnV and then look in the EnV file for
something that that corresponds so if I
literally maybe just copy this and
Define it in here this is where we're
going to save it okay great so process.
env. language model API key we're going
to look in here for that and grab
whatever we put here in order to
populate this and save it as the con
language model API key so that's one
thing we're going to have to do we're
also going to get the
language model
URL and this again we're going to get
from the documentation so let's do it
let's go to the paltu page and let's get
that API
key okay so there is my API key please
do generate your own I'm going to
disable this it won't work make sure to
get your own and keep it safe great now
for the language model URL so we're
going to be using the model URL here I
however as of recent Palm 2 has also got
some methods that you can get from
certain packages if you install them so
just keep that in mind I'm just going to
go super basic like I said this is a
very basic tutorial and use the model
URL so the model URL for this is
https and then we're going to go with
generative language Google apis Thank
You tab 9 it's completed it for us I'm
checking if it's right goi.com
V1 it's actually V1 beta 1 and then
maybe let's just delete this as that is
not correct models and we're going to
get the chat by
son
model generate message
model and then we're just going to get
the key which which is our API key and
essentially pass it through so language
model API key that is correct so that is
the whole
thing there we go I'm just making sure
that it's correct again so models we're
using the generate message model and
there we go make sure that's in back
ticks otherwise this code will not be
picked up and we're telling our code
editor that this is Code by since using
the dollar sign and passing it through
Kylie braces like so great so we've got
our language model URL let's move on now
we can write a request so what we're
going to do is essentially send some
text from the front end to our back end
and then send it over to the pal to API
so we can get a response right so we're
going to ask a question and get a
response so let's write our root we're
going to use the get method for this and
I'm going to say that if we go to Local
Host 8,000 SL prompt slash and we're
going to get the text from the URL so
that is how you do it just zoomed in so
you can see it a little bit better this
is going to be an async method where we
get the request and the response and
then we're going to essentially get that
text from you using request param text
so we can Define it here yeah you can do
it like this or you can do
it like so it is up to to you so there's
our text now let's define our payload
pay load
equals and this payload is actually
taken from the documentation we're going
to have to get the
prompt and then Define the
messages that are going through so we're
going to pass through a whole array of
them like I said each time we're just
going to be sending through one message
okay this is just one message that we're
sending over and we're getting a
response so let's send over that one
message essentially an object and that
object is going to have content and the
content is literally going to be this
text okay so that's what we're sending
over to the API we can also set a
temperature for this okay so here's our
prompt object in fact maybe just to make
it a little bit more readable I'm just
going to make it all on one
line
like so so there's our prompt next we
pass through the
temperature I'm going to set it as
0.1 and the
candidate count which is going to be a
one as well now that we have that we can
get the response so let's define the
response this is going to use fetch
which is an async method so we use use a
wait and then we're going to pass
through the URL that we're going to
visit along with headers so let's set
some
headers we're going to do content type
application Json and then as the body
we're going to get the payload and just
pass it through Json string ofi and this
is going to be a post method so there we
go so again what we're doing is we're
sending this over so all of this with
the text from the URL to pom 2 and
essentially to this end point
essentially right so it's going to this
end point along with all of this stuff
and then let's await that response so
let's await the response let's get it
Json but uhoh this is an async method so
we use the await keyword and let's save
it under data and once we have that data
just going to send it back okay okay
great so at the moment this will
actually work uh I won't have to do much
let's just console log this data at the
moment too I can simply go SL prompt and
then hello so this text of hello is the
text po over into the URL right and
there we go so once again the text was
hello that's what we passed through to
the back end and Center over to the Palm
2 API as you will see here so there's
are messages there is just one message
and this is the response that we are
getting from Palm 2 hello how can I help
you today so now let's display that here
right so we got the question and the
answer we've got the data let's display
it we're also going to have to pass
through this word from the front end so
here rather than just typing it out like
so so this should be relative L painless
let's do it so let's go back to the app
I'm going to have to import state so
import use state from react we're not
going to need use effect and next we're
just going to save the state of the text
so const text set text and new state is
going to be an empty string to start off
with and then we're also going to save
the messages that come back so we're
going to call it
messages just to keep kind of in line
with the messaging so
far that has been used so
messes set
messages and this is going to be an
empty array to start off with just like
so so in order to get the response so
cons get response this is going to be
async method and when do we want to get
the response well as soon as we click on
this button so on click of this we're
going to get the response and we're
going to get the response by essentially
using the value in the text area so here
again I'm just going to make sure that
the value is the text so currently that
will be an empty string and then on
change of anything in this text area I'm
going to set the text so we're going to
get the
event and set text so we're essentially
changing the state of text to be e
Target
value okay just in case you do not
believe me that we are changing this I'm
just going to console log it out console
log text so you can see
it so in the console log here now if I
right hello that is text Cu we're conso
logging out the con text and it's
constantly changing so now that we have
the text let's send it over to the back
end so that we can get the response so
I'm going to define the response I'm
going to use await Fetch and we're going
to pass through literally the back end
so Local Host 8,000 make sure that says
8,000 use back ticks here as we're going
to essentially write the end point which
is this okay so you can just paste it
like so I'm going to replace this with
code so once again we get the dollar
sign the curly braces and we're just
going to use text so that is now the
equivalent of us essentially writing
this out
essentially maybe let's get rid of that
and what do we do with the response well
we're going to grab the
response get it Json like so let's await
this as well and save this as data and
then once we have the data we're
actually going to set the messages right
here so we're going to set messages and
then we're going to essentially open up
an array and whatever messages already
exist okay so at the moment Nono we're
going going to get those and then append
a new object so we're going to make a
new
object just going to put it down here so
maybe it's a little bit more readable
for you and our objects are going to
look like this well we're just going to
have the author and we're going to get
that data that comes back to us so we
know what this looks like we saw it
before go into the messages we're going
to go into the first as it's always
really going to be one message and we're
going to get it content okay because we
saw it before we had the messages
content which is the messages that we
sent over and then we also have data
candidates content and that was what the
API sent back to us and we'll save this
under bot so we've constructed this
object okay we've just made it up
because this is what we're going to use
in order to map onto our divs okay cool
so let's try this out I'm also going to
console log messages here so we can see
what's going on and I'm also actually
going to console log the data here just
so again it's just really obvious what
is going
on so
data messages and let's try this out so
once again let's just stop Fresh So
messages and States currently nothing
however if I write hello okay still
nothing this is our text and I send this
over suddenly this is the data that
comes back right like I said this is
what it looks like we've got candidates
and we've got an array at the moment it
just has one item in there and it's
essentially the response from the API
hello hi can I help you and then we also
have messages in here and this is the
message that we sent over author that's
us and the content hello okay cool and
then once we get that dat to back I'm
essentially using it to create our own
object so this is the object that we
created I've just got author and Bot and
we've just taken the content from both
of these and stuck it in our own object
so we just stuck in a message in here
and I'm going to map the content of this
object onto these two so this is easy
I'm just going to go down here let's
comma this out for
now I'm going to grab the messages and
if they exist I'm going to map each m
message we're going to have an index as
well we're going to map it fact we don't
need that on to all of this so just like
so let's uncommon this out just like
that so I'm just going to delete this
and wrap this in something so let's make
a new div this is actually going to hold
our key as well so there we go just C
cut that paste it in here and then for
this I'm going to have a key and is just
going to be the
index great so now onto here as the text
I'm going to go into the message and get
the author so once again this is just
from the object that we made we're going
into the object getting author and then
we need to do the same for bot so
perhaps I'll just copy this and then
write bot so if we save that we will be
able to see it and if I write something
else let's write how are
you and send that
over you will see now there are two
messages in here however if you look in
data okay it's still just the
one message that comes back because
we're not sending over all of that data
to the API okay we're just sending over
the text so essentially this text right
here just keep that in mind as each
question will be unrelated to another
okay if you want to of course expand on
this you're more than welcome to I'm
just pointing that out that you know
when you're having conversation it won't
build on its previous knowledge it will
treat each question as an individual
question unrelated to the previous great
so we're seeing all of that one last
thing however because if you look in the
feed uh we need to be able to scroll so
let's go back to our CSS
s so maybe let's grab the whole feed
just like that I'm going to do position
absolute bottom 82 pixels to kind of
space it up on the bottom left
positioning zero width I want it to be
100% of the parent and height I'm going
to constrain it to be 250 pixels so we
can scroll through it so I'm going to do
overflow on the Y AIS scroll okay okay
so now we should be able to scroll and
this is looking great another thing we
can do is if we are you know seeing some
dodgy Behavior here maybe we need to
also position the X AIS so it's always
in
front I'm just going to grab the
header so the chat header right
here and do
position relative
Z index
one okay and that is now much better
great so hopefully that makes sense I
hope you found this useful and I hope
that you can share your chat Bots with
me please take them build them maybe use
different models start them up I'd love
to see what you have made please tag me
on socials on Twitter and yeah I hope to
see you again on another tutorial soon
yeah